Speaker 1: All right.
Let's get into our mailbag.
It's the Friday mailbag.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com
if you have a question, comment, concern,
anything you want to demand a correction for.
Occasionally we will grab a comment from YouTube
or sometimes Facebook or sometimes a tweet
or whatever the case may be.
Let's get right into it, as we often do, starting
with some criticisms, which is fine, D.L.
or Patrick, I don't know.
Wrote in and says Biden should be in jail.
Family corrupt over 40 years.
Where have you been?
Maybe you haven't been around long enough.
Please read all info on Biden's laptop.
Both dad and son should be in prison for all
their dealings with China, Ukraine and other
countries.
They have made millions from money laundering.
I know you know this with a question mark.
This is the type of person where we just need.
There's not enough time between now and the
election to talk sense into someone like this.
So my advice from a voting standpoint is we
just have to find two new voters to cancel
out this guy's vote.
I mean, one, I guess to cancel it out, but
then a second one to actually make some progress.
I don't see how someone who is in such a fantasy
world that their one contact with me is to
tell me how everything about my perspective
is wrong because it lacks the stuff from the
Biden laptop and Biden and Hunter should be
in prison that I don't think we have the time
capacity to just argue and change these people's
minds.
If you think there's some way to fix these
folks brains, let me know.
But I think it's much simpler to register
people to vote and to cancel out their votes.
Next message is from Kara.
Kara wrote it and said, Your F-ing Nazi baiter,
boy.
Well, I'm Jewish, so I don't know what you
mean by Nazi, but my family fled the Nazis.
Kara goes on, There are hundreds of millions
of Trump BS who will make sure your voice
is silenced on social media as ours have been.
Who the f are you?
Well, if you don't even know who I am.
Why is it important that hundreds and millions,
hundreds of millions of Trump is silence me?
If I'm so insignificant that Kara has not
heard of me, I don't know why anyone would
need to waste any time silencing me.
By the way, it's really interesting how the
delusions seem to spread virally.
And what I mean by that is recently Trump
pulled this idea that there's hundreds of
millions of MAGA people at his last rally.
Trump said something like, Oh, there were
the 75 million who voted for me, plus another
150 million, probably like so.
So Trump believes that there's 225 million
Trumpists in the United States.
Now, correct me if I'm wrong.
Number of adults in USA 2022.
What are the number of adults?
I actually can't find that.
Anyway, the point is 225 million maggots.
It's like it's got to be close to every adult.
I don't know what percentage of the population
is under 18, but it's got to be 20% or more.
Anyway, as usual, as is the case with these
people, the numbers never add up.
The numbers never add up.
Thank you, Carol.
I appreciate that.
Okay.
Mike wrote in again asking about these spam
messages that he's getting.
Mike says, I've received this message a couple
of times in response to comments made on Dave
Pacman YouTube clips.
Question is scam or legit?
I don't use WhatsApp, but I am curious and
it's one of these messages where the user
has my picture as their profile picture and
it says Write me.
I know that this is a disappointment to some
in the audience.
Some people will write to me and say, David,
I was so excited that you wanted to hear more
from me about my view on, you know, Hillary
Clinton or whatever that I tried writing you
on WhatsApp like you told me.
I am not asking anyone to text me or to WhatsApp
me or anything.
These are scammers.
Report them to YouTube.
We are doing everything we can to get this
scourge.
As Trump would like to say off of YouTube.
As far as I know, no one's been scammed so
far, but eventually they will ask you for
money.
That's the scam.
And at some point I'll do an expose, a bigger
picture on the full scam.
But no, I'm not.
What?
Zapping anybody.
I'm not texting anybody.
I don't want you to text or WhatsApp me.
It is a scam.
Do not fall for it.
Jada noticed an anomaly on our Social Blade
page, which tracks our YouTube channel.
Jaden said, David, Sir, I was looking at the
social blade for your YouTube channel and
I noticed that as a graph of your subscriber
increases.
I have tears in my eyes as I tell you that
it appears that the machines have been dumping
new subscribers of 10,000 every couple of
weeks.
There are huge gaps and irregularities that
cannot be explained.
Please, sir, we need pillow on the show so
he can explain how the machines did this.
You know, a few people have written to me
and they said, David, is there a scam going
on with your subscribers?
Because you get none for days and then suddenly
10,001 day.
Let me explain on YouTube.
Once you get to a million subscribers, the
algorithm shifts into tracking them in tens
of thousands.
So like when you look at our YouTube channel,
it'll say 1.47 million subscribers and then
it'll go to 1.48.
So it tracks them in 10,000 increments.
When that is the case, Social Blade does the
same thing.
So in reality we get like 600 subscribers
a day, but it only updates now every 10,000.
No scam going on, check any channel above
a million subscribers and you will see it's
the same.
Michael wrote it.
Michael says, David, I sincerely want to thank
you for the public service you do in showing
the liars and hypocrites on your show.
I think it's a very necessary, but I can't
bear to watch some of the outrageous clips
you show.
So I mute the sound and just listen to your
commentary to learn what nonsense was said.
You must have a great deal of self-control
to be able to listen to Trump and the maggots
day in and day out.
Well, I don't know if this is a good thing
or a bad thing.
I've talked about this before.
There is a desensitization that happens when
you do what I do, where because outrageous
things happen so often, they start to seem
less outrageous.
And that's why it's good, number one, to take
time away from this stuff.
And number two, to talk to people from different
places.
So when I talk to family of mine from other
countries or even when foreign callers call
in or when I read articles about American
politics from other countries, it's always
good to have sort of your sensibilities reset
because it's nuts here.
This MAGA right wing authoritarian wannabe
fascist movement that is written about here
by Michael.
These people are genuinely dangerous, and
it's also not typical.
It's really not typical, and it's good to
get that perspective from other countries.
Daniel wrote in about Mike Pillow.
And says, David, do you really think it's
appropriate to have Mike Lindell on your show
again after his manic episode on Facebook?
It's clear Mike is unwell.
Inviting him on again almost seems wrong.
Like we're making fun of someone who needs
a doctor.
Anyway, just a thought.
Let me know what you think.
Daniel from Indiana says, Don't have pillow
on because he's he's mentally ill.
I mean, I don't know that we know that.
And honestly, probably like 20% of our guests
are mentally ill by some definition.
I don't know.
I don't know what the standard should be,
the tough one, but I'm willing to hear from
people in the audience.
Aaron wrote in and writes in about CNN's right
turn.
Aaron says, Hi, David, I'm a progressive,
possibly a little to your left on some issues.
But I have to say that I'm not scandalized
by CNN's decision to drop the Big Lie moniker,
even though it's very clearly a big lie.
Don't you agree that the term sounds quite
editorialist thick for a news segment?
I'm not convinced that a commitment to more
neutral language is, in fact, a turn to the
right.
No, listen.
On the CNN right turn, it's no one thing.
It's not over dropping the big lie alone.
It's a combination of things, including statements
made by the new CEO or president, whatever
he calls himself.
The big lie thing is one element changes the
staffing.
It's a lot of different things.
Recent comments from anchors.
I would never make the case that just based
on not using the term big lie anymore.
CNN is now FOX News.
That wouldn't be accurate.
It's not what I believe.
But go back to the segment I did on it, and
it's a much bigger picture issue than that.
Rodney wrote in about abortion and said Hello.
Should a registered or voting Republican be
allowed to get an abortion in the United States?
I get the point of this question if you vote
against abortion being legal.
By voting for elected officials who will try
to make it illegal should you be allowed to
get an abortion.
It is so outside of any legal framework to
deny abortions based on how people vote.
That my opinion is.
Here's here's my thought, Rodney.
Okay.
And I really appreciate the message.
I get why you're asking the question.
It's a losing direction to go in saying, okay,
make abortions illegal for Republicans because
they want it to be.
We're almost as bad in saying deny a legal
medical procedure to people.
Right.
And so, no, I don't think that that's a good
idea at all.
Gabriela wrote in about Democrats, quote,
winning, and she makes a good point.
Gabriela says, Hello, sir.
My dad used to tell me when I would ask, who's
winning during any sports game?
Well, no one wins until the end.
They're only ahead for now.
I thought this might be relevant to your recent
clip on Democrats leading across the country,
albeit not by enough.
They're ahead for now, but it's up to voters
to help them win.
100% correct.
And this is why every time we look at 2022
polling numbers, Senate forecast, House forecast,
I always say this is where we are right now.
There are things not yet reflected in the
polls.
Everyone must vote.
And I hope that you will.
And we're starting to get down to the wire.
If you have never voted before, at least Google
voter registration deadline in your state
and understand when can you register?
Can you register same day?
It's very important to know that.
And I hope every single one of you votes.
All right.
Monday, 919.
The David Pakman Show membership special.
We're going to be blowing out memberships
at rates never seen before at a huge discount.
The theme is 919.
That's the date.
If you would like to be notified about this
membership special, you need only get on my
newsletter at David Pakman dot com.
We'll see you on the bonus show and back here
on Monday.